vous êtes hafid yolande qui est vous
vous battez depuis de longs mois pour
que toute la lumière soit faite sur ce
drame et pour faire changer les choses
un drame incroyable puisque depuis de
longues semaines votre maman ne se
sentait pas bien et les médecins
décèlent notamment une myocardite une
embolie pulmonaire et une pneumonie la
veille du drame elle se rend aux
urgences de mots explique que des
douleurs reviennent après quelques
examens pourtant mauvais le médecin
l'autorisé à quitter l'hôpital à 3h30 du
matin
ils l'ont laissé partir vous étiez déjà
inquiète pour elle vous voyez vraiment
qu'ils aient vu qui a été vraiment pas
bien oui j'ai vu qu'elle était vraiment
pas bien et enfin je suis tombé des nues
lorsque ma maman à 3h30 du matin mme
envoie un sms pour me dire laura
écoutent ils m'ont laissé sortir est ce
que tu pourras venir d'ici dix minutes
pour m'ouvrir la porte du garage donc
j'ai dit bon ok d'accord j'étais un peu
groggy un peu un peu stupéfaite et j'ai
ouvert la porte du garage donc dix
quinze minutes après pied et on a
discuté quelques minutes mais je lui ai
dit maman écoute je comprends pas tu
m'avais dit que ton le cg n'était pas
bon que ton taux de troponine n'était
pas bon et ont laissé sortir m 10 dans
une sorte de résignation bah oui m'ont
dit que ce n'était pas normal mais que
c'était normal ils m'ont donné nord une
ordonnance de paracétamol et puis et
puis voilà on a pas on n'a pas plus
débriefer que ça parce que le jour même
on devait déménager en normandie donc
moi je suis retourné me coucher pour
essayer de prendre des forces pour cette
journée et ma maman est là je me
rappellerai toujours de son dernier
repas entre guillemets elle a pris une
une tartine de
de la brume tranche de tartines brioché
je vais y arriver et une un petit bol de
lait végétal qu'elle n'a jamais qu'elle
n'a jamais fini en fait parce que très
enfin elle n'a pas dormi et à 7 heures
du matin 7h30 de huy 7h30 lewis et
douleur s'intensifie au point qu'elle
décide d'appeler le seul c'est d'abord
l'assistante de régulation médicale qui
reçoit son appel est d'emblée elle
semble s'impatienter alors que l'on
comprend que yolande ne va pas bien du
tout je vais écouter
d'accord enregistrements que vous ne
souhaitez pas écoutés
ils vous ont dit quoi exactement c'est
quand il y en a perdu maintenant il me
lit beau il ya bientôt deux trampolines
encore
immobile bon c'est bon il va falloir que
je suis chez moi mais que ne soit une
redite comme ça et comment celui-ci
était 12h la main les longueurs peut
comprendre
alors madame moment où madame madame oui
ok on va calmer je vais entendu parler
maintenant fond de répondre
donc bah là on a entendu ce premier
appel
finalement elle transfère l'appel au
médecin régulateur et dice va se montrer
encore plus impatients écoutez
médicaments
et médicaments tout le quai oui
pour l'a compris
il faut vous calmez vous avez pas trop
mais
je suis calme et vous ne savez que vous
prenez comme médicament vous avez pris
votre ordonnance avec vous et oui le
vert
loi
là on voit c'est vrai qu'il ya des
réponses
correspondent pas ce qu'on attend voilà
d'une personne en souffrance l'antenne
votre mère était vraiment très mal à ce
moment là elle était elle était très
très mal en fait elles vives et
pénultième instant en fait parce que ces
derniers instants les a vécus avec c si
donc ma soeur jumelle et moi donc voilà
elle et elle était très très mal elle
suppliait pour pour avoir de l'aide de
l'assistance voilà que le médecin qui a
prêté serment et qui lors de ses
premiers cours de
médecine il a appris le prime ne sert et
puis l'empathie boxe ce médecin lui
témoignent de l'empathie et puis accepte
de lui venir en aide et malheureusement
là elle n'a pas eu ça donc l'appel s'est
étiré alors ça c'est bon maintenant on a
d'autres d'autres extraits de l'appel
vous allez voir c'est incroyable le
médecin semble croix rouge ou à croire
que yolande ne fait qu'un caprice quand
on sait la fin tragique de cet appel
parce que c'est les derniers instants de
yolande 1 sat à peine écouté cet
enregistrement vraiment fait froid dans
le dos et alors là vous nous rappeler
c'est quoi votre intention
nous avons alors qu on va pas faire ce
que vous voulez d'accord si vous voulez
aller à jossigny vous y allez mais si
vous appelez des services de secours en
période de garde vous irez là on le
sentait mieux organisés mais je suis je
suis sorti les
narguer
ceux qui se donnent à
voir j'ai d'autres extraits dans
l'instant oui ce qui est fou c'est
l'enchaînement d'abord l'hôpital de
meaux qu'il allait sortir puis le samu
qui ne prend pas en compte c'est un
terrible enchaînement comme si on
n'avait pas voulu l'écouter et jamais
j'ai regardé tout le dossier jamais on
ne prend en compte sa douleur comme si
en fait elle a sa bulle est qu elle
inventait exactement exactement c'est ça
qui est incroyable enfin yolande va même
se voir crier dessus par le médecin
quand panique a soufflé au plus mal elle
ne parvient plus à bien parler dans le
combiné écoutes et
arrêtés donc je vais vous renvoyez moi
je peut vous renvoyer une ambiance mais
je vous ramène aux urgences deux mots
ils ont votre dossier c'est là où vous
étiez allé la première fois et on va
assister en disant que vous êtes en bété
et ils vont vous reprendre
si vous parlez pas dans le téléphone on
peut pas s'entendre là je vous disais
je vous entends pas qui nourrit quelques
noms mais [ __ ] mais parler dans le
téléphone c'est à paris mais qui sait
après cet appel
yolande a immédiatement fait un malaise
juste après cet appel qu'est-ce qui se
passe j'ai donc
juste après l'appel est le elle
elle raccroche et
jeu quand je suis descendu geagea et
pardon j'ai entendu de l'agitation en
bas et je suis arrivé à la fin de la
conversation en fait et j'ai vu ma maman
dans le salon en train de chercher son
ordonnance voilà j'ai pour le coup j'ai
vraiment entendu ses passages au val
d'isère attendez attendez j'ai senti
qu'elle cherchait quelque chose et donc
du coup donc elle raccroche et judy
maman qu'est ce qui se passe sans
qu'elle dit ça va pas bien le samu est
arrivé je suis pas bien quoi et donc
elle commence à s'agiter et ma soeur en
temps de l'agitation en banque et en os
donc elle descend et donc voilà je dois
donner ce détail un peu un peu intime
mais il faut savoir que voilà maman
s'agite elles vont aux toilettes elle à
el hadjar et parce qu'avec ma soeur on a
vu que ma à lui des choses sur sur
l'agonie est l'un des symptômes de
l'agonie enfin l'un des signes de
l'agonie c'est par le relâchement
musculaire et tous les 5 cartes qui
lâche donc ella ella ella aller alors
quoi elle est allée aux toilettes et
après elle s'est effondrée et c'est ma
soeur jumelle qui là qu'il a un nom elle
et elle a eu le temps de
de tirer la chasse et puis de revenir et
puis ma soeur l'a réceptionné parce
qu'elle s'est effondré sur le sol de la
cuisine donc elle a accompagné dans sa
chute et après à partir de là ben tout
tout le reste de la matinée se passe sur
le sol de la cuisine qu'est ce qui se
passa donc que l'aller elle passe par
tout par toutes les phases de l'agonie
donc on a lu plein de choses dessus donc
voilà je vois qu'elle est très pâle
qu'elle a le teint cireux je compare mes
paumes avec les siennes jeudi mais
christine tusse pense pas qu'elle ait
froid de l art des sueurs froides après
la chaux il faut savoir qu elle qu elle
s'est effondrée elle était juste en
petite culotte et elle trouvé la force
de nous dire les filles s'il vous plaît
habillez moi le samu arrivé donc on
essaie de lui mettre son soutien je sais
tu es tellement je la seule chose que
j'ai pu y mettre c'est une paire de
chaussettes et donc elle disait j'ai
froid donc je suis allé chercher une
couverture après j'ai chaud donc je les
ventiler elle m'a dit j'ai soif l'aura
donc christina allait lui lui prendre de
l'eau est aujourd'hui mal oui ma soeur
jumelle pardon et j'ai dit non non
christine le sérieux va arriver
peut-être qu'ils vont devoir l'opérer
très rapidement il faut que son estomac
soient vides humidifie lui plutôt les
lèvres donc on a fait elle a fait ça et
puis plus ça allait plus ses dernières
paroles et est un concentré en un
contre-un si pardon voilà la fin c'était
c'etait deja lago nique et enfin le le
dernier souffle koala elle a crié et
puis c'était fini il ya de légumes qui
c'est qui s'écoule et deux du côté de la
lettre et puis c'était fini quoi et puis
je vous avoue que pendant une fraction
de seconde on a cru ma soeur et moi
parce que maman
comme beaucoup d'aidé des soeurs de la
famille gabriel s'endort très très très
vite donc pendant une fraction de
seconde on s'est dit ah ben ça y est le
mal est passé elle s'est endormie et
puis ça va aller est très très
rapidement je commence à me dire mais
mais attends j'ai l'impression que la
poitrine se soulève pas donc je commence
à paniquer jeudi christine j'ai pas la
force mais tu mets ton oreille sous le
sous la bouche de maman est ce que tu
sens son souffle est ce que tu sens que
la poitrine se soulève m 10
chais pas j'ai l'impression ces
intermittents et là le pire scénario se
profile dans mon esprit je suis dit oh
là là [ __ ] [ __ ] seigneur et de nous
comme enfin voilà enfournez les
chrétiens catholiques bon ça très
pratiquante mais si à un moment il faut
prier c'est bien là donc je dis oh là là
c'est pas possible ça me va arriver le
samu arrivé donc je me dis bon on attend
enfin on est là on est un peu comme hors
de nos corps on voit la situation donc
je dis bon je vais rappeler le samu donc
là il est 8 heures 8h24 j'appelle le
samu donc là j'ai affaire à une petite
dame je crois donc jeudi excusez moi
excusez moi le maman appelé il ya pas
mal de temps normalement il ya une
ambulance qui devait arriver est ce
qu'elle va enfin arriver parce que là
elle a faim de malaise j'ai l'impression
qu'elle respire plus donc l'opératrice
du samu me donne me dit écoute et je
vous passe le médecin et donc il sait
pas c'est quand même un assez long
moment entre guillemets avant que le
médecin me parle et donc j'ai mis le
portable / / / haut parleurs et là je me
dis waouh là vraiment maman elle respire
plus donc je dis dans le doute laura je
pose pas de questions tu fais un massage
cardiaque tu commences à ma charge et
donc j'essaie de me rappeler de mes
cours de secouriste sud lors des comme
ça donc les espaces intercostaux et
gnagnagna et des trois catégories et je
je je masse et jeudi à christine parce
que c'est extrêmement fatigant de faire
un massage cardiaque j'ai dit à
christine kristin
tu fais comme ça tu fais pas comme dans
les films tu tu vois là il faut vraiment
que ce soit ou ton poids qu'ils soient
sur le corps de ma lancée et a et deux
et trois et quatre histoires qui tu
comptes comme ça et voilà donc on sait
on s'est relayé
et j'ai eu le la dame du samu la médecin
du samu au téléphone et donc je lui dis
donc voilà madame maman a fait un arrêt
m10 à d'accord auquel les secours
devraient arriver mais je vous envoie
une ambulance plus rapide avec une
équipe médicale mais en attendant
commencé un massage cardiaque jeudi oui
mais on a déjà commencé a dit parfait
bien continuer les secours vont bientôt
arriver
raccrochée donc on a raccroché et les
seuls à l'ambulance privée que le
médecin avait dépêché pour maman enfin
des péchés c'est très bizarre
j'utilisais ce vocable lorsqu'on sait
que l a pris plus d'une heure quinze
pour arriver donc l'ambulance a fini par
arriver à
8h40 c'est ce que dit le rapport du
salon en sachant qu'ils ont pris et non
ils ont pris leur temps pour pour
arriver quoi j'ai dû aller ouvrir la
porte du garage pour bien me dire que
c'est cette maison parce que cette arme
un ancien corps de ferme avec une cour
commune donc j'ai ouvert la porte je les
ai vus arriver tout à fait
tranquillement ils ont pris le temps de
pour se garer de l'autre côté de la de
la cour commune donc je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas eu l'information paix la dame
chez qui il se rendait avait fait un
malaise et voilà j'en ai dit c'est ici
c'est ici et c'est quand ils ont vu ma
soeur qui me relayait qui était au
dessus du corps de maman et je me
rappellerai toujours de l'intonation de
de la petite dame de l'urgentiste est la
belle charlotte sur la tête
massage massage et c'est là qu'ils se
sont bougés enfin qu'elle sait bouger
parce que la peau peut être elle pouvait
pas savoir et c'est là que l adie pousse
toi ma puce c'est bon je prends le
relais son collègue est arrivé avec un
défibrillateur semi-automatique
et c'est le seul matériel qu'ils avaient
bas pour maman parce que c'était pas le
smur n'ont qu'ils n'avaient pas le la
machine qui mme hakima s'aide elle-même
il avait pas les il n'avait pas les
drogues donc elle a pris la relève de ma
soeur et puis j'ai j'oublierai jamais je
l'entends du teaser je crois que j'ai
cassé une côte donc je ça m'a fait mal
parce que c'était maman mais je sais que
lors d'un massage cardiaque une cote
peut arriver mais je me suis dit elle a
déjà agoniser maintenant lui cassent une
côte je sais pas dans quelle mesure elle
encore consciente même si on sait que
est elle est morte avec nous a eu entre
8h24 et 8h26 mais ça fait quand même mal
de disques ou deux battants de sa maman
elle est sur le sol de la cuisine en
plus on lui a cassé une côte dans un
geste de secours bien sûr mais ça
rajoute du de la tristesse
incroyable alors c'est bouleversant
témoignage de laura tout le monde est
bouleversé un sur le plateau jours les
téléspectateurs également
comment vous comment vous a expliqué
après coup ce mauvais aiguillage et ce
médecin qui n'en voit qu'une ambulance
privée au lieu d'envoyer un smur qu'est
ce qu'on vous dit après coup pour
expliquer cette erreur monumentale mais
en fait on a on a pas eu d'explication
puisque aujourd'hui
on n'a pas eu de contact avec le
directeur du samu
77 ni avec ceux le médecin il faut
savoir que ma soeur jumelle elle a écrit
un courrier de cinq pages au mois
d'avril à la alain à l'intention du
docteur du enfin du directeur du samu
une lettre de cinq pages où elle posait
des questions très précises comment ça
se fait que ce docteur l'a dit fortin
dans le téléphone et tout ça parce qu'on
a on a demandé la retranscription quand
même comment ça se fait que même le seul
le médecin du samu à faire oui ekoko
quand comment ça se fait et on a reçu
une réponse tout à fait un kuryk et
lunaire une vingtaine de jours après où
il nous a juste envoyé une page
oui et se contentait de refaire
l'historique ils nous donnaient des
données qu'on avait qu'on avait déjà en
fait et c'est la seule chose qu'on a eu
avec un autre petit bout où il disait un
autre papier où il disait que voilà nous
restons à votre disposition pour une
tentative de médiation pour parler donc
voilà on avait sur le coup ma soeur
voulait répondre mais on a demandé
conseil à notre pénaliste il a dit non
non non surtout surtout ne répondait pas
donc on a on n'a rien répondu et donc on
n'a pas une nouvelle et c'est seulement
le journaliste de médiapart qui nous a
fait savoir avant l'article qu'il a
publiée mardi qui nous a fait savoir que
le samu avait accepté de répondre entre
guillemets à ses questions et nous a
fait savoir que le directeur du samu 77
ans refusait de parler de faute pour lui
ce médecin et un médecin d'expérience
pour lui il a assuré la continuité des
soins il reconnaît voilà il reconnaît
que mon qu'il a fait preuve de mouvement
d'exode des aspirations a justifié et il
s'en excuse mais
et c'est tout ce qu'on a eu et le
médecin du samu ne nous a ne nous a
jamais demandé pardon n'a jamais cherché
à rentrer avec nous et on a appris qu'il
est toujours en fonction aujourd'hui et
qui n'a ni blâme ni pas même une petite
[ __ ] sur la main alors que je
comprends pas ils n'essaient même pas de
se cacher savent que mediapart aller aux
jo il n'essaie même pas de entre
guillemets de mentiras nom se mettent à
ce médecin était sanctionné il est plus
dans le service non non tout va bien
tout est tranquille où il est là voilà
c'est assez et c'est assez fou c'est fou
qu'un merci laura d'avoir été avec le
soir soit témoignage était très
important pour nous mr c'est vous avez
on avait on a utilisé les audio 1 de
médiapart voilà je le dis ce soir voilà
et c'est vrai que c'est important de les
entendre et que le plus grand nombre
entendre tant de ces audio de cette
histoire incroyable merci beaucoup
j'aimerais est ce que c'est possible de
rajouter un gibbons a un petit truc oui
donc je vous remercie vraiment je dis je
n'ai je vous remercie de moi ma soeur
jumelle et mon papa de nous permettre de
de faire entendre la voix de maman et je
sais que le journaliste de mediapart a
fait un incroyable travail et avant et
avant lui la journaliste de france
antilles celle inaugurale et voilà le
journaliste de france antilles pardon de
de mediapart pardon
a choisi un angle pour son pour son
article donc il a insisté à ces sur le
racisme et voilà j'ai été interviewé
pendant longtemps et j'ai dû beaucoup
plus j'ai dû beaucoup de choses et voilà
j'ai pas envie que le drame de maman de
vienne à un étendard antiraciste c'est
voilà je pense qu'on est puissant mais
l'angle de l'article du journal et de
médias bas
on est obligé quand même de se dire
qu'il n'aurait peut-être pas
complètement tort ce qui compte après
c'est vrai que voilà le
moi j'ai lu l'article et c'est vrai que
ce qui soulève c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
bien vu oui après c'est juste qu'on veut
pas que le drame de maman soit souvient
le porte étendard de l'antiracisme on
est plus intelligent que les méchants
blancs et gentil noir il faut savoir que
maman dans tout son parcours de soins
j'ai rencontré ses médecins on allait la
voir tous les jours à l'hôpital elle a
rencontré des médecins qui venaient de
tous les horizons donc si j'ai évoqué le
syndrome méditerranéen et je crois même
que j'ai parlé au conditionnel c'est
seulement pour ce maillon de la chaîne
ce médecin parce qu'il faut savoir par
exemple j'en veux pour preuve que le
médecin le cardiologue qui l'a laissé
sortir à trois heures du matin je les ai
eus au téléphone deux jours après il
avait un gros accent africain ou
maghrébin
donc c'est pas une affaire de couleur
c'est vraiment une affaire de demande
d'humanité de manque d'empathie voilà où
est le premium nos séries où sont les
principes éthiques de bouchons et
chaleur est c'est on dit que l'hôpital
va mal certes mais je pense que notre
humanité notre sens de la compassion
d'un malheureux